if there's one thing you know about
sloths it's that they're well slow but
that doesn't mean they're boring
in fact sloths are one of the most
extreme animals on the planet and not
just because they poop
only once a week first of all sloths
really are extremely slow their top
speeds clocking at just point to five
kilometers per hour making them the
slowest mammal on the planet according
to zoologist Becky cliff that's because
well sloths
can't really see 60 million years ago
they lost the ability to see they went
almost completely blind so in the day
time a sloth actually can't see anything
because it's too bright if you can't see
what you're going you can't run around
if you're going to fall out the tree
moving slowly may sound like a liability
especially if you're nearly blind but
being sluggish actually comes with all
kinds of benefits for one they save an
enormous amount of energy
in fact sloths use about 90 percent less
energy than the average mammal which is
vital considering that Dyer is a low
energy snack consisting of leaves where
the side of leaves and as it turns out
being slow also helps slots avoid
detection
you see sloths are so slow that
predators like Jaguars and Eagles which
use movement to hunt can't even find
them but some sloths take predator
avoidance to the next level thanks to
rare extra vertebrae and its neck the
three fingered sloth can turn its head
270 degrees which allows it to smell
incoming predators from almost any
direction and that's especially useful
when you spend nearly all of your time
motionless in a tree in fact sloths
sleep mate and even give birth
all while hanging upside down on a
branch and as you might expect that
requires some pretty extreme adaptations
they've got special tendons in their
hands which lock into place and along
with their long hook like fingernails
allow them to hang easily like a giant
coat hanger and to combat a rush of
blood to the head which might be
familiar if you've ever hung upside down
they have special in their circulatory
system that does actually stop the
pooling of blood in the head but if you
think that's extreme consider this once
a week sloths risk their lives on a
daring journey from the protective
forest canopy to the ground their
mission to poop and it really is risky
we suspect about 60% of predator base
sloth deaths happen while are pooping
they literally risk their life to come
down to the ground so they have to make
it count and boy they really do sloths
can lose an astonishing 30% of their
body weight each time they go plus they
might get a made out of it how do you
find a mate if you're solitary and you
can't move very far well they're gonna
have to use pheromones and scent markers
I think that coming down and leaving a
little pile at the base of your favorite
trees is sort of like a little signpost
but if there's one thing that really
pushes slough over the top it's their
rough fur sloth fur has it's very own
ecosystem because they live in the rain
forest it's often wet which creates the
perfect environment for algae to grow
and provide sloths with green camouflage
but it isn't just algae that calls a
sloths fur horn you can also find
beetles cockroaches and a species of
moth that's found nowhere else in the
world except for on sloths and the
sloths does seem to mind one bit but
that's not all their fur might actually
save lives fungi in their fur have been
shown to fight breast cancer cells and
they may also have properties for
fighting malaria so despite their slow
pace sloths are far from boring and in
some environments they aren't even slow
I mean look at that daredevil girl
you